musulmane dans aborder la politique avec
un homme que vous ne voyez pas souvent
parce qu'il a jusqu'à présent refusé les
projecteurs du moins en ce domaine il
s'agit du commandant Coustau aujourd'hui
pour le journal Antenne 2 il accepte de
répondre aux questions que se pose avec
insistance un certain nombre de militant
écologistes que représente assez bien
gus dans ce dessin alors la première
question mon comandant vous êtes oui ou
non candidat à l'élection présidentielle
bien je vais quand même vous expliquer
le cheminement de ma pensée dans C
difficile décision j'ai reçu un nombre
incroyable de sollicitations par écrit
euh un nombre de lettres qui avoisine
40000 qui en fait se réduit à 25000
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
mont écrit 5 ou six fois et même une
fois 14 fois on vous aime bien en gros
on aimerait que vous soyez candidat en
gros ou mais
euh ces gens-là il faut quand même il y
en a qui représentaient des associations
des groupes des gens importants euh qui
se battent depuis des années pour
l'écologie je ne pouvais pas traiter ça
par-dessous la jambe
malgré la ma réticence à m'intéresser
aux luttes politiciennes que j'ai
toujours
manifesté leur insistance ça posait pour
moi un cas de conscience le cas de
conscience j'ai consacré 3 semaines en
ne faisant que ça pratiquement j'ai
interrogé tout le monde j'ai interrogé
les principaux candidats j'ai interrogé
les chefs des principales formations on
est venu discuter avec moi chez moi et
ailleurs j'ai aussi interrogé oui et
j'ai aussi interrogé en dehors de ces
lettres ce qui m'intéressait dans ces
lettr il avait deux lettres sur TR qui
me disaent soyez candidat une lettre sur
TR qui me disait non vous allez créer la
division bon mais à côté de ça j'ai
interrogé des tas de citoyens dans la
rue des porteurs de bagages des marchand
de journaux des cafetiers des chauffeurs
de taxi et cetera et c'était eux qui
m'intéressaient et
95 % me disait vous allez tout de même
pas vous occuper de ça vous bon alors là
vous faites du suspense vous êtes oui ou
non candidat et
bien je vais quand même vous avant de
vous donner ma réponse je vais quand
même je vais quand même vous dire que
vous donner les arguments qu' avit pour
et les arguments qu' avit contre que
vous suiviez un petit peu ma pensée hein
c'est quand même je crois que ça
intéresse tout le monde savoir pourquoi
je je prends une décision alors les
arguments pour c'était que ces
présidentiels donnent l'occasion
d'exprimer au public avec la télévision
largement
ouverte les doctrines des écologies
et des doctrines qui sont souvent mal
comprises par le public qui voi les gens
les écolos comme des gens qui veent
retourner au cavernes et ce ce qui n'est
pas vrai bon et la deuxième argument
c'était que ça permettait de se compter
et de si on avait un bon score de
pouvoir influencer les pouvoirs
établis le premier argument est bon
parce que malgré le taux bruit électoral
effectivement des gens auraient pu
s'exprimer deème argument est un petit
peu moins bon parce que le compte des
électeurs qui votent écologiste n'a rien
à voir avec le nombre des véritables
écologistes en France en France tous les
sondages montent qu'il en a au moins 30
% mais des gens qui votent il y en a 4 5
6 7 % bon par conséent il y a un divorce
complet entre le nombre de entre si vous
voulez la France écologique réelle et la
France écologiste légalous vous faites
comme les hommes politiques vous
répondez pas aux questions vous
présentez ou pas je vous donne je vous
donne mes deux arguments contre
maintenant vousz après quand même oui
tout de suite alors les arguments contre
c'est d'abord qu'à l'origine j'avais pas
l'intention d'être candidat quand
chercher bon
euh ma candidature créait effectivement
une division puisqu'il y a des gens qui
se sont intéressés qui ont qui ont
comment posé leur candidature depuis
déjà longtemps un candidat de plus ça ça
aurait jeté le le discrédit et ma
véritable vocation finalement c'est de
m'occuper de défendre la vie de défendre
l'eau à une échelle globale c'està-dire
que mes interlocuteurs valables sont pas
les gouvernements ce sont les
organisations intergouvernementales
c'est-à-dire
la les Communautés européennes les
Nations Unies l'organisation africaine
l'organisation Sud sud-américaine et
cetera donc je crois avoir compris vous
vous présentez pas alors tout bien pesé
j'annonce aujourd'hui officiellement que
quoi qu'il arrive quel que soit les
pressions qu'on fasse sur moi en
remerciant beaucoup tous ceux qui ont
fait cette pression je ne serai pas
candidat au Président c'est définitif
c'est définitif c'est pas un caprice de
St qui veut se laisser un petit peu
encore
courtiser oui alors cette décision
entraîne quand même un certain nombre de
conséquences ça ne veut pas dire que je
me désintéresse du mouvement écologique
en France au contraire donc si vous
voulez la grande leçon pour moi de cette
méditation c'est de me dire peut-être
que tu ne t'es pas assez occupé de ton
pays pendant ces dernières années que tu
as voulu voler trop haut par conséquent
j'ai l'intention de m'occuper plus des
questions de mon pays à l'avenir que je
m'en suis occupé dans le passé alors
j'ai renforcé cette action française de
l'écologie en même temps j'aiderai les
mouvements écologiques au président
justement volonsbas un petit pour qui
vous allez voter pour qui vous allez
appel à voter ne me demandez pas ça la
parole est aux écologistes c'est eumême
qui désigne leurs candidats et je
suivrai la discipline c'est-à-dire que
je soutiendrai leurs candidats
c'est-à-dire apparemment il a encore il
en a encore plusieurs mais oui alors si
vous voulez j'espère que très rapidement
une union sera faite sur un seul nom je
crois que ça va se faire et euh ce ser
plutôt lequel hein plutôt lequel plutôt
bris euh c'est qu'est-ce que vous pensez
non je vous pose la question vous je
crois que la parole est aux écologistes
la parole est aux écologistes et je
soutiendrai quel que soit leur candidat
je le soutiendrai et en même
temps je les appuierai et j'essaierai
également d'éviter certains excès de
paroles qui donneent une mauvaise image
de l'écologie profonde bon cet homme-là
il faut qu'il ait des signatures pour
l'instant pas signatur c'est signature
c'est l'occasion je vais être très bref
mais donnez-moi l'occasion de dire ce
que je pense euh je pense que le système
des 500 signatures nous ramène à
Napoléon 3 c'est som toute l'élection au
2e degré c'est vraiment très très
mauvais au point de vue démocratique
j'aurais préféré si on voulait faire une
barrière ce qui est logique que on
demande par exemple aux candidats de
rassembler 200 300000 signatures de
citoyens ça ça voulait dire quelque
chose actuellement nous en sommes par
conséquent 500 signatures de Mair alors
je profite de cette occasion pour lancer
un appel solennel au maire de France
ceux qui hésitent encore a donneré leur
signature au candidat écologiste devrait
bien penser que ils donnent leur
signature à des idées il ne donnent pas
leur signature à une personnalité hein
par conséquent qu'ils fassent le examen
de conscience s'ils sont en faveur de la
protection de la nature et de
l'environnement qu'il donne qu'il
soutienneent le candidat écologiste et
au deuxème tour entre les grands
candidats jiscar mitéran Chirac de bre
qu-ce
que surt n'allons pas nous mler de cette
affaire quand même il pas plus
écist écoutez
euh tous les candidats sont d'accord
pour renforcer les questions contre
lesquelles nous nous battons
c'est-à-dire les quatre grands partis
sont d'accord pour renforcer l'énergie
nucléaire faire voler Concorde et cetera
qui sont des des choses très bien au
point de vue au point de vue
technologique mais qui présentent des
dangers pour la population qui sont
impossibles dans le cadre nucléaire et
des côtés économiques catastrophique
dans le cas de Concord j'ai pris Concord
plusieurs fois c'est un avion
merveilleux mais ça ne tient pas de bout
au point de vue point de vue économique
les les contribuables paient les voyages
des des riches privilégiés alors parlons
mon commandant de ce que va être votre
combat maintenant qui va pas être
uniquement électoral de ce que va être
votre combat écologi pour la la
suite je me suis battu et je continuerai
à me battre et là où les les désastres
arrivent pas par exemple en Méditerranée
en Méditerranée euh en 1900 il y a 31
ans exactement euh nous au Grot du
virron au large de Marseille trge de
Marseille nous visitions ça c'est en
noir et blanc parce qu'à l'époque nous
filmions en noir et blanc c'était bourré
de poisson la vie était intense la la
flore était intense également nous
avions i des Corbes qui ont complètement
disparu des méroues il n en a plus et
les poissons de passage il y en a très
peu aujourd'hui bon mais quand nous
sommes revenus 31 ans plus tard et cette
fois quand nous avons voulu filmer en
couleur dans cette grotte nous avons été
complètement sidérés de voir le désastre
écologique c'est-à-dire nous travaillons
ns premion dans un désert vous voyez là
euh en 1944 hein vous avez tous ces tous
ces poissons de toutes sorte dans la
grotte elle-même du Viron que vous allez
reconnaître en couleur et qui sera vide
au même endroit précisément au même
endroit là nous avons des mérous qui
venait nous toucher qui venait qui
venait jouer avec nous et après cette
cette période ça a été la la je pense
qu'on a voilà 1977 vous voulez plus de
poisson il y a plus de poisson plus rien
nous sommes promenés là-dedans pendant
longtemps alors d'où ça vient ça ça
vient évidemment de de pollution mais ça
vient aussi de destruction mécanique et
la question est très grave elle a lieu
en Méditerranée elle a lieu au Caraïbes
et cetera notre organisation se battra
au point chaud où qu'il soit dans le
monde entier bien doncant je vous
merercie d'avoir donc annoncé en direct
devant nos caméras que vous ne serez pas
candidat au prchain é
présidentielleonce ce soir